[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Applaus]
hab schon so
[Gelächter]
ab 15
[Musik]
einer muss vorangehen
der zum glück noch keine da
[Musik]
auf und davon nach uruguay die
emmentaler rudi und susann althaus
wollen eigenhändig eine ferien lodge
bauen
in der letzten folge bereiteten sie in
uruguay alles für ihre auswanderung vor
in turbenthal im kanton zürich übergab
josef almeida dass bei dem brett fest an
seine mutter mit ihren kindern brachen
sie nach kanada auf dort wollen all my
dass ein altes modell übernehmen
und an der nordsee versuchen sascha und
brigit kunst ihr glück mit einem
imbisswagen in baselland räumte die
familie ihr haus und so bis zum umzug in
den norden zu briketts mutter
[Musik]
schildbach im emmental
die kochtöpfe müssen mit im neuen leben
in uruguay möchte die 52 jährige susan
gäste bewirten wohl die un susan wollen
eine passage eröffnet eine art ferien
lodge mit restaurant und swimmingpool
jetzt räumen sie ihr einfamilienhaus
dass sie vor 20 jahren selber gebaut
haben hier in der schreinerei des vaters
ist rudi aufgewachsen hier hatte er als
bausteine gearbeitet bis es ihnen
irgendwann in den kosovo zog zur
militärmissionen wie das whisky zurück
in der schweiz nahm er 2006 eine stelle
beim bund an die kaffeehauskette gerät
die mtm offen
der luft das geschah es am hof aber dann
reden wir das ist so berichtete springen
punkte das machen
das haus in dem sie ihre drei jungs
aufzogen haben sie bereits vermietet in
sechs wochen bricht ehemann ruhe die
nach uruguay auf susan kommt nach sie
arbeitet noch ein paar monate länger in
der schweiz etwas geschick und ein paar
möbel
vielmehr lassen sie im emmental nicht
zurück
gleichzeitig machte bist du ja noch das
sehen wir jetzt vier monate kennt dann
bin ich ja wort in eine kita und dass
ich jetzt nach chaudhrys kia regen
friedenstage zurück zusammen haben sie
schon viel geschafft sogar eine trennung
haben sie gemeistert und sich wieder
zusammengerauft
jetzt krempeln sie ihr leben noch einmal
komplett um
im august sollen zur pension
ein letztes mal den familienalltag mit
den drei jungs genießen bevor das alte
leben vollends in kästen verschwindet
das ehebett ist schon geschichte
was bleibt ist lohnt
[Musik]
mattews peripherie zu schließen ist
sicher vermessen zu glauben schreibt das
wort ist kein start-up mit demenz der
sowjetisch setzt sich mit griff begriff
balinesen schweiz und weissrussland
dadurch linie sache daher sollte das ja
nicht einfach so zusammenkommen
dass wir den uruguay nicht mehr gehen
[Musik]
die strapazen der reise stecken beatrice
josef und in kindern in den knochen
es ist bereits nach mitternacht als
familie almeyda nach drei langen flügen
in halifax ankommt dass ihr neuer
nachbar erwartet sie schon
vor 24 stunden sind sie unter tränen in
turbenthal im kanton zürich aufgebrochen
auf schotter sehr
einmal klar vor augen geführt und es ist
definitiv ist aber es ist noch nicht so
richtig bis zum herbst oder truhen hat
das design für emmerich
den weg zum neuen daheim fährt josef
nicht zum ersten mal
das reservat werden ist erst seit zwei
jahren kommen die allein das regelmäßig
hierher
jetzt wollen sie wurzeln schlagen im
eigenen haus in der nähe des ortes täter
markus die familie hat den ehemaligen
bauernhof während der ersten ferien in
kanada entdeckt und gleich gekauft
darunter ist durch die decke
warum ich irgendeine schlage es hat
alles besser was die nazi verbraucher
einfacher ist praktisch aber es ist
nicht so schlimm ist eigentlich nur
besitzer von acs hatte das haus hat acht
zimmer im ersten stock durften sich die
kinder je eines aussuchen
es gilt also die ist das aussehen die
sache
die erste etappe ins neue leben ist
geschafft
[Musik]
naja aber auch bezahlen daher sollten
in läufelfingen bei familie kunz gibt es
allen grund zu feiern
die zwillinge timo und noemi werden 13
und die familie kann endlich los ins
neue heim an der nordsee doch zuerst
heißt es noch einmal möbel schleppen die
letzten wochen kann die familie bei
sascha schwiegermutter unter das eigene
haus ist schon verkauft
froh ist man sich über drei gigawatt ob
es in der causa ganzes gegangen und
kevin der große sohn fährt zusammen mit
seinem kollegen davis den möbelwagen im
imbiss an der nordsee ist kevin als
mitarbeiter fest eingeplant deutsche
plan macht ubisoft vor noch hinter dann
mit der hofmeister gates klaus t
[Musik]
großmutter susan hilft nicht nur beim
einladen sie wandert gleich mit aus
[Musik]
für das neue zuhause hat sie sich noch
ein paar möbel gekauft
wenn die haube hat alles fix fertig
immer markt ist das ein wunschtraum
[Musik]
dann geht es zum abschiedsfest sascha
und frisiert haben für die feier eine
waldhütte gemietet 70 leute haben sie
eingeladen
familie freunde und arbeitskollegen
setzte sich sascha und prickelt freuen
sich auf die chance die sich ihnen mit
dem imbisswagen bietet dafür lassen sie
viele verwandte und freunde zurück
ein abschied mit gemischten gefühlen
[Musik]
kein tag wie jeder andere auch in bern
ruhe die uns und michael sind auf dem
weg ins pentagon so heißt wo dies
arbeitsort im verteidigungs- der
parlament im volksmund
heute dreht ruhe die seinen job an
seinen sohn ann-kathrin stück ist rudi
chefin in kommando sie hat michaela aus
verschiedenen bewerbern für roadies
nachfolge ausgewählt berechnungen die
herren dr
bis jetzt ist sie passt es auch rund
zwölf jahre lang hat der ruhr die eine
zivile anstellung zuerst in der
kommunikation später beim schießwesen in
leitender funktion war er für die
traditionellen schweizer schützenvereine
zuständig
[Musik]
noch ein paar tage die gewohnte
sicherheit in bern
dann tauscht der 53-jährige ruhe dies
einen schreibtisch beim bund gegen säge
und hammer in uruguay anderthalb jahre
plant er für den bau der ferien dodge
dann sollten die ersten zahlenden gäste
kommen
monatelang habe die polizei auf
das ist jetzt versteht dann gegen die
linke sei aber das verstehen ist einfach
fertig
[Musik]
der erste morgen im neuen heim von
familie almeida
bis vor zwei tagen servierten sie um
diese zeit in der schweiz das frühstück
für ihre gäste mit irgendwie retter
drüber und ritter und und mit der zeit
tagt dann erstmals für große sehnsucht
und wir sind in der anderen hand das
gesehen da die elite oder plant das ist
einfach so unglaublich schön
und da ist das herz ist in einer schon
fast 68 hektar fast 100 fußballfelder
sowie land können die alma dass ihr
eigen nennen
[Musik]
mit dem auto ist es eine viertelstunde
bis ins nächste dorf
[Musik]
dieter makus ein ort mit gut 800
einwohnern
[Musik]
direkt an der durchgangsstraße liegt der
zukünftige arbeitsplatz der auswanderer
[Musik]
keine zwölf stunden nach ihrer ankunft
in kanada haben sie ihren ersten termin
sie sind mit ihrem makler ralf und dem
bisherigen besitzer verabredet team
führte das modell 17 jahre lang zusammen
mit seiner frau sue altershalber wollen
sie es abgeben
den kaufvertrag haben all my das bereits
unterschrieben
aber bevor sie das geld überweisen
wollen sie das gebäude noch einmal
begutachten
das haus wurde er 1967 gebaut
das letztere hatten jim und zu hier vor
einem halben jahr zubereitet im winter
hatten sie das hotel geschlossen
[Musik]
es hat 18 zimmer gut dreimal so viel wie
das bed and breakfast almeidas in der
schweiz ist der hammer
ihr müsst eigentlich nur selber machen
für das haus müssen sie umgerechnet 350
tausend franken auf den tisch legen
viel geld aber für josef stimmt es
es kann hier in münchen das ja natürlich
nein ist es nicht seine einschätzung für
kanadische verhältnisse ist das
eigentlich nicht mal so schlecht oder
nicht das ist was gutes über deutschland
im emmental lädt ruhe die zum ausstand
ja er habe das als rücklage muss ich
sagen das ist sehr schön sie fragen was
sie mit euch zusammen zwei metern länge
meter oder weniger lang als kompliment
wir haben uns aber gut dass wir wünschen
dir und auch die jesus alles gute auf
dem weg richtung uruguay es witzig kann
nicht immer einfach werden aber ich
denke erfolgreich sein
später wurde ein richtiger braucht
natürlich auch eine bärenfalle und nicht
nur die schweizer fahne und sein ruf und
ein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
susannes tränen werden nicht die letzten
sein denn der abschied hat für die
emmentaler erst begonnen
[Musik]
bester film auf
nur noch alles ins auto packen dann geht
es für den 50 jährigen sascha und seine
frau brigitte in lich los der große sohn
kevin ist mit dem möbelwagen schon auf
dem weg nach norddeutschland
die zwillinge timo und noemi hingegen
bleiben noch bei ihrer großmutter bis
das schuljahr zu ende ist schwierig das
ist in sechs wochen kommen timo und
noemi nach zusammen mit großmutter susan
[Gelächter]
o
[Musik]
900 kilometer weiter nördlich ist der
möbelwagen schon fast entladen
kevin ist vor ein paar stunden
angekommen
gemeinsam mit seinem kollegen davis ist
er die nacht durchgefahren
momentan fehlt die ferien aber es wird
roters der heime werte das ist komisch
viel service economics nur noch ein paar
kilometer dann haben es auf sascha und
prägt geschafft sie sind am ziel
nach zehn stunden auf der autobahn und
falco und katze roxy haben die lange
fahrt scheinbar gut überstanden
[Gelächter]
die baselbieter haben bereits freunde
die sie erwarten
nachbarn dreh und seine familie haben
schon einen teil der möbel
zusammengebaut
das heimathaus ist schön
private und halver sich cool offen
angeschlossen nein
dre wohnt mit seiner familie gleich
gegenüber
die schweizer haben ihn erst vor ein
paar monaten kennengelernt als sascha
und prägt das haus renoviert 20 jahren
kennt
[Musik]
und zug gelungen einen besseren start
hätten sie sich nicht wünschen können
[Musik]
an der tegge schritt schneller academy
beginnt eine neue schulwoche die busse
mit den schülern kommen erst in einer
halben stunde familie almeida aber ist
schon da für rubin saphir und andré ist
es der erste schultag in der neuen
heimat joseph und beatrice haben die
kinder schon vor zwei monaten hier
angemeldet anders als in turbenthal
gehen alle drei in dasselbe schulhaus
schulleiter brian holmes erwartet die
familie schon
traurig sei dass der achtjährige robin
versteht kaum ein wort in der
primarschule hatte er nur ein paar
monate frühenglisch
ja genau
ja ok viel spaß
aber winter mit darunter das hier macht
das finden kunden als auch unsere mehr
ganz und gar nicht haben das ist
speziell
aufstand
[Musik]
stelle
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist ziemlich amerikanisch
der erste schultag für beatrice fast
aufregender als für ihre kinder
[Musik]
diesseits des großen teichs beginnt für
ruhe die das abenteuer
das amt mit
in uruguay möchte ruhe die mit dem bau
der ferien lodge beginnen
er fliegt mit einem alten kollegen seine
frau susan bleibt noch vier monate hier
und verdient weiter geld für das
bauprojekt
vielmehr dem feststellt dass sie da
bliebe und grundsätzlich bin ich froh
dass er jetzt ist kann ja als handgepäck
mit
zu sagen ihre drei söhne und susannes
eltern hin zum flughafen mit gekommen
boston
laut
aus
[Musik]
17 stunden mit zwischenstopp so lange
ist rudi nach uruguay unterwegs
[Musik]
ja
jetzt sammeln
[Musik]
in kanada bekommen alle mal dass
regelmäßig anrufe aus der schweiz
die beiden verwalten noch immer die
buchungen für air bed and breakfast in
turbenthal sind josef mutter führt jetzt
zwar das gästehaus aber sie hat mit den
buchungen nach wie vor probleme
und nach diesen arbeiten mit einem sind
aktive zählte diego herum hand und ist
sehen wir zwei reduzieren und dann auch
geklappt
trotz doppelbelastung ein guter tag für
josef und beatrice denn der kauf des
modells steht unmittelbar vor dem
abschluss
[Musik]
das einzige was noch fehlt sind die
schlüssel
[Gelächter]
anderthalb jahre haben sie auf diesen
tag hingearbeitet
aber ich sehe auf den beruf vor leere
und die neue team und so wollen den
beiden noch mit rat und tat zur seite
stehen
bis ich einmal das im hotel
zurechtfinden
[Musik]
unterdessen geht auch der erste schultag
zu ende
heute holen josef und beatrice die
kinder ab künftig sollen sie mit dem
schulbus fahren das macht nicht
glücklich
die erste hürde haben die kinder
gemeistert
[Musik]
zum sonnenuntergang zieht es sascha und
prägt als mehr
[Musik]
direkt am kutterhafen steht er in
wiesbaden den sie in ein paar wochen
übernehmen wollen
der ehemalige vertreter und die gelernte
krankenschwester wagen den sprung ins
kalte wasser
also eigentlich nur speziell das noch an
den vom juli werk das in serie aber
sieben tage in der woche wollen sie hier
pommes und currywurst verkaufen
vorher aber muss der wagen noch mit
ihrem logo beklebt werden
25 jahre steht der imbiss schon am hafen
jetzt will in der besitzer abgeben
ins rollen gebracht wurden die
auswanderungs pläne der familie in den
letzten ferien eigentlich ist darüber
ganz ganz links im ecke ganz klar yorks
dass der margen verhelfen und das team
hat das wirklich sehen kann und ist der
notruf automatisch und stellt und ross
mitarbeiter wachsen eigenen augen sieht
dass man bereit unseren teil
[Musik]
familie kunz und die nordsee was einst
als ferien flirt begann könnte zur
ernsthaften liebesbeziehung werden
[Musik]
große party am wattenmeer in der
nächsten folge
sascha und bringt übernehmen den
imbisswagen schlüssel haben jetzt
brauchen sie dringend noch den passenden
wurst lieferanten in uruguay könnte ruhe
die mit der ferien lodge loslegen
doch er kann sich noch nicht mit der
baufirma einigen und im hotel in kanada
geht nichts mehr
unerwartet der stress für josef und
beatrice bereits tauchen die ersten
gäste hat
[Musik]
kunst offen
auf und davon
mit der mobiliar versicherungen und
vorsorge